à son agenda ce soir doit s'exprimer
devant la station f
et pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
nouveau gouvernement
est-ce qu'on a une question à votre avis
qu'est-ce qui se passe
du tout bon la vérité c'est d'abord je
pense que nous autres journées sont
suspendus à cette affaire un peu par
fonction commentateurs aussi assemble de
responsables politiques sont suspendus à
cette affaire après je pense pas qu'une
angoisse absolument phénoménale et règne
le pays en se demandant alors est-ce
qu'on a un remaniement ou pas de
remaniement bon une fois qu'on a dit ça
c'est un peu notre métier de regarder et
c'est vrai que ça fait huit jours qu'on
attend et huit jours que ça coince de
c'est un fait pourquoi parce que c'est
un rom c'est d'abord un remaniement
c'est toujours compliqué celui là l'est
je pense doublement d'abord parce que
d'abord c'est un remaniement qui sert au
maniement subissez pas un choix ce
maquereau n'a pas décidé de changer
maintenant il a vu un ministre partir un
important ministre est donc maintenant
il faut qu'il trouve il faudra passer
donc l'europe sache c'est plus compliqué
est deuxième et enfin dernier point de
complexité c'est l'intérieur l'intérieur
c'est pas un ministère comme les autres
c'est un ministère qui exige de plein de
qualités différentes prémices de
l'intérieur c'est les questions de
terrorisme et de sécurité évidemment
c'est aussi des questions électorales
c'est l'homme qui va faire le
redécoupage électoral
c'est quelqu'un qui s'occupe de plein de
choses de renseignement et qui aura
plein de secrets entre les mains donc il
faut qu'il est absolument la confiance
absolue du président et du premier
ministre
donc tout ça fait que cette affaire
n'est pas simple et donc ça traîne
voilà donc ce n'est pas un drame mais si
on veut essayer de comprendre les choses
pour le dire simplement ça ça coince
al'inverse de ce que disait olivier
duhamel la semaine dernière olivier nous
disais ici même qu'avec la démission
suivie de colomb macron s'est fait
piéger par son obsession de maîtriser
les horloges en faisant durer le plaisir
il reprend pas un peu la main non c'est
en refusant ge dans mon souvenir
l'athlète l'espèce de vis tu es comme
deezer c'est à dire que refusant de
laisser partir collomb quand il
demandait à partir quitter le bon sens
même il sait coin il s'est piégé ça
aurait été plus simple de dire quand que
l'on a dit que finalement je songe à
autre chose ça veut dire merci tu t'en
vas
cela dit ça n'aurait pas simplifier le
le choix du remplaçant de colomb et je
pense que si macron précisément ne veut
pas laisser partir que l'on ça n'est pas
uniquement pour dire c'est
le chef et c'est lui qui décide c'est
aussi qu'il ne sait pas par qui le
remplacer
la preuve il ne sait pas par qui le
remplacer on en revient toujours à la
même question c'est quand même très
simple la vie on a quelqu'un qui s'en va
il faut trouver quelqu'un pour le
remplacer
et si on ne trouve pas c'est plus long
que prévu et ce qui est pourtant simple
d'habitude afin avant macron c'est qu'on
arrive quand même à dans ces cas-là
remaniée s'est assez rapidement je remet
simplement oui sauf que souvent les
remaniements et comme prévu à l'avance
comme l'a dit alexis brézet à l'instant
c'est un remaniement particulièrement 1
subie qui suit un remaniement raté enfin
remaniement bornes et si je veux dire
c'est à dire le remaniement qui aurait
pu avoir lieu après le départ de nicolas
hulot aurait été assez logique
il y avait une attente là on voyait des
carmes quelques ministres on disait
qu'ils étaient remplaçable pour le mois
et là il y avait on est à la rentrée
après un été difficile on pouvait penser
que rsa banon après la crise au de
crédibilité personnelle qu'a subies le
présent de la république durant l'été et
dont nicolas hulot a été un nouvel
épisode
et bien non il a préféré temporiser
faire une promotion interne et
cannibalisé en quelque sorte la
république en marche pour remplacer
nicolas hulot et là il se retrouve dans
une crise tout à fait importante
alors pourquoi est ce que c'est
important peut-être moins pour l'opinion
française en général
et là c'est le sondeur qui parle qu'on
est désolé à l'elysée on dit c'est pas
on n'est pas sous la quatrième
république en plus on part on pense pas
non plus que ce remaniement correspondre
à un tournant de la politique économique
ou autre
donc c'est pas un événement politique de
première ampleur pour les français là
aussi un peu plus embêtant c'est en
train de se passer c'est en pillant
cette ambiance comment dirais-je
d'improvisation de l'embarras qui semble
se dégager peut-être contre noah une
surprise incroyable tout sera tous mes
propos seront annulés enfin pour
l'instant où nos jours alors on parle
c'est comme cela qu'on ressent c'est
gênant non pas pour l'opinion en général
mais c'est gênant pour les cadres la
politique pour les élus la réplique en
marche à un énorme problème c'est pas
les élections européennes enfin pas
seulement
c'est surtout les prochaines élections
municipales et là il ya c'est le
praticien qui parle un tout petit peu
les gens je voyais en juin dans les
communes de france demandaient les élus
se demandait comment avoir l'investiture
de la république en marche pour 2020 en
septembre il se pose
autre question c'est pas comment
l'éviter faut pas exagérer mais en tout
cas c'est un peu la question portée de
tout cela moi je m'en vais et surtout se
prendrait pas pour lyon la bastille sur
un match c'est colt c'est quand même un
signe annoncé c'est à camoufler
d'ailleurs c'est ce que dit ce que dit
le dernier sondage aux docks ça mais
béatrice giblin votre analyse
il est plus facile de remplacer un
général cinq étoiles que de remplacer un
ministre intérieur stablement ça c'est
d'évidence beaucoup plus simple en place
un général enfin ça dépend si on veut
qu'il soit très bon c'est peut-être un
peu difficile on peut pas forcément
savoir mais on revient ce jeu revient
sur la démission du dos là aussi on est
quand même dans quelque chose qui est
subi l'eau aux annoncé à france inter un
matin qu'il n'a même pas prévenu le
président de la république le premier
ministre et qui le mec comme ça sur la
table
c'était aussi très très inédite cette
affaire là donc même un remaniement
juste après cette démission public du
lot même si on pouvait se dire et finira
par en avoir assez les couleuvres il va
cesser de vouloir les avaler néanmoins
ça aurait été sous une décision qu'il
n'avait pas prise et c'est là où
effectivement on peut s'interroger parce
que il se dit que le premier ministre
edouard philippe souhaité un remaniement
déjà depuis quelques temps c'est à dire
qu'il préférait un remaniement à froid
après un été effectivement qui a été
pour le moins perturbée et de repartir
avec une équipe avant même de faire
cette rentrée il n'a pas été entendu et
maintenant dans la volonté de d'emmanuel
macron de refuser la démission dans un
premier temps de colomb je pense qu'il
n'a pas pensé que l'on n'était pas un
homme d'état il a surestimé le
personnage il s'est dit il ne peut pas
faire ça on va avoir des échéances
extrêmement importante
il ya même un g6 des ministres à
l'intérieur à lyon en ce moment il a il
a ne s'attendait pas à ce jeu c'est
l'analyse que j'en fais à ce qu à ce
qu'il peut à ce qu'ils puissent
manquer à ce point à sa parole et à ses
responsables et à ses responsabilités ce
qui est de la naïveté de la part du du
président de la république a surestimé
sa capacité d'influencé d'autorité sur
kolo score vient le voir les enjeux veut
partir il lui dit non tu pars pars
maintenant et l'autre dit bon bon
d'accord et la malle du film ans je me
suis abonné et je vais démontrer que je
pars je pense que c'est vrai on peut
faire cette analyse là vous leur posez
sur un acte exclusivement d'autorité
voilà je te dis non tu pars pas on ne
sait pas le contenu de cette de ce qui
s'est dit vraiment vous avez peut-être
déjà en train que je n'ai pas mais ça a
pu l'être il a annoncé au figaro qui a
démissionné à commencer par la réception
de démissionner
comment vous avez tout suivi d'un et
même prévenu le premier ministre m
en pleine assemblée nationale donc vous
étiez effectivement aux premières loges
voilà mes bons pour en revenir à savoir
ce que je trouve tout à fait étonnant
c'est comment quelqu'un comme comme
colons en ce moment aussi important pour
bon pour le pays dans ce rôle qui l'a de
ministre de l'intérieur
oser faire des sorties comme il les a
faites en partant c'est quand même
invraisemblable
enfin le problème ça c'est le problème
de la justement de l'autorité qu'il a
défié de l'autorité
défiez du président mais pour revenir à
ça excusez moi mais au delà de
l'autorité défier du président il était
en charge en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur en particulier sur les
banlieues dont le plan de borloo a été
traité mais énormément mis à la poubelle
en deux temps trois mouvements vous ça
va bien les plans banlieues alors qu'on
sait très bien qu'il ya un problème de
fond et qu'on n'a pas mis tant d'argent
de ça dans les banlieues depuis depuis
aussi aussi longtemps que ça et qu'il
ose dire l'heure est grave
il faut vraiment s'occuper des banlieues
la république n'est plus maître dans
certains quartiers ben oui et qu'est ce
que tu as fais toi depuis 18 mois ce
n'est pas ton boulot ça ça c'est quand
même invraisemblable de dire une chose
comme ça va moins vite et pour ma part
en tant que citoyenne parfaitement
choqué
philippe torres que cette ce choc et ce
scandale ressentie par béatrice giblin
il est ressenti à l'étranger également
en ce qui concerne l'euro m'anime
aujourd'hui absolument pas je veux dire
que pour moi alors il ya deux choses je
vis en france je vis la vie politique
française comme vous tous les jours et
bon gré mal gré je sais que c'est pas
facile pour macron je reviendrai sauce
comprend de lui depuis la grande
bretagne dans un instant mais il ya des
choses qu'on sait déjà on sait que
probablement ça va être un grand
remaniement ça pas être de prendre deux
ou trois personnes les met à la page 2
ou 3 personnes parce que ça traîne donc
pour mâcon ça serait plus propice de
faim
tissot dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
renommé depuis le perron de l'elysée à
nouveau un nouveau gouvernement de faire
la photo et c'est à eux de faire un
discours politique générale c'est un peu
tôt en gros pour lui de le faire parce
qu'il doit il fallut attendre après les
élections de l'année prochaine sont eux
les élections européennes avant de faire
le gouvernement macron 2 mais il a eu la
main forcé justement par gérard colomb
que je trouve rancunier après laffaire
benalla gates je pense que c'était la
goutte qui a fait déborder la vase et je
pense que colom a senti trahi par macron
parce que il a pris un bain à la comme
un gars de course on lui en parle et je
pense que c'est là où ça vraiment car
contre des églises ont sonné juste pour
vous mener sur la l'image de maquereaux
à l'étranger je vais être un peu dur
avec vous parce que je pense que vous
rendez par contre la perte de la
personne que vous avez en france qui est
toujours très bien vu depuis l'étranger
même s'il est moins bien vu ici parce
que c'est le seul vraiment en europe qui
peut contrer trempe qui peut au
contraire poutine qui peut proposer le
renforcement de l'union européenne face
à merkel qui est quand même très
affaiblie la grande bretagne et qui est
en plein bourg excite malheureusement
donc bon il faut pas trop le le mettre à
la poubelle aussi macron bosquet il sait
a quand même à quelque chose même vu de
l'étranger par par nul et les
journalistes étrangers à paris c'est le
cas c'est le vase qui a qui a déjà
débordé mais il y a on fait parfois des
sondages à l'étranger pour se voir
l'image des présidents etc
comment dirais-je je m'étais convaincu
qu'il était bon pour un peuple que son
président soit parfaitement populaire
dans les autres pays
c'est souvent à ce même parfois un
indicateur trompeur voire
contre-productif
je prends ces problèmes qui affectent
2030 en france vous avez l'exemple de
salvini par exemple salvini et très
populaire en italie
il a une image
très mobiles ont d'autre part tous les
pays européens mais dans d'autres pays
comme le nôtre je pas sûr que ce soit un
indicateur si vous voulez très très
décisif le fait qu'il ne connaissait le
pré le ministre italien et une mauvaise
image en france que ce soit les
indicateurs que sa politique soit
particulièrement mauvaise pour revenir
sur votre sur ce point comme phrase
l'aspect c'est un homme qui sait parler
à tracter par la poutine l'a justement
on touche un des problèmes de la période
pour le pouvoir français pour emmanuel
macron il avait effectivement installés
durant son élection et puis après son
élection
7 comment dirais-je même l'impression
d'un pouvoir quasiment magique
si vous voulez d'un charisme
extraordinaire et que grâce à sa
personne il allait pouvoir résoudre tous
les problèmes qu'ils ne l'étaient
n'allait pas été auparavant et qu'il
pouvait justement convaincre par son
magnétisme personnel monsieur travail
monsieur poutine etc et qui pouvaient
résoudre aussi les problèmes de du vieux
monde
eh bien on se rend compte au cours des
derniers mois que d'une part cette
séduction supposé pour monsieur trump et
bien ne donne pas de résultats tangibles
à ma connaissance comme monsieur poutine
non plus on renvoie pas et qu'au niveau
français en tout cas et c'est de désaveu
qui valait de camoufler qu'il a subie
avec le ministre de l'ecologie bhl
ministre l'intérieur sont la preuve que
cette magie justement n'opère plus ce
charisme à mon avis a disparu dans la
tête des gens on prend les questions des
internautes
joan kennedy pourquoi ce remaniement est
il si loin à venir et bien on l'a
expliqué au début de cette émission
jeunes c'est parce que notamment le
remaniement est un remaniement subi et
j'ajouterais que on touche du doigt
laquelle une des faiblesses
objectif de cette année et demie de
mâcon c'est l'incapacité dans laquelle
il a été par uniquement de sa faute à
mettre en place une relève dire que son
grand paris c'était quand même je vais
renouveler
la pratique politique renouvelé les
hommes ben finalement un an et demi il
n'y a pas d'homme nouveau qui soit
apparu il n'y a pas de nouveaux qui sont
parus et les anciens s'en vont parce que
ben hulot s'en va bayrou est partie que
l'on s'arrête donc si les vieux parts et
que de nouveaux n'apparaissent pas il se
retourne et on cherche on cherche on
trouve pas et ça c'est quand même pour
l'avenir c'est comme chose de
préoccupant c'est que si macro n'arrive
pas à structurer un dispositif partisans
avec des individus autour de lui comment
il va faire pour la suite
les européennes ya les municipales fait
une vie politique ne veut pas retenir un
qu'on peut gagner une élection
présidentielle sur un homme mais ensuite
et c'est peut-être ça une des erreurs de
macron c'est de croire qu'on peut
structurer une conquête et une pratique
politique et une perpétuation politique
sur un homme et un moment il faut
s'entourer et c'est ce que disent ils de
vicky et ça c'est le le défi qu'il a pas
ce qu'il fait justement c'est ce que
dira les internautes c'est parce qu'il
n'ya pas le même vivier que les ps et l
air d'antan concernant le remaniement
babineau lui dit c'est un remaniement de
face à lille essaye d'apporter un vent
de fraîcheur mais ces règles qui fait
non productifs
il faut un électrochoc pour nous faire
pour faire basculer l'opinion publique
un remaniement est clairement
insuffisant dit babineau qui dit un vrai
remaniement serait de remplacer le
premier ministre qui est absolument
inexistant alors justement le premier
ministre et bien il est un peu sous
pression en tous les cas sous la
pression des questions des journalistes
depuis ces dernières heures et il s'est
notamment exprimé hier soir en écoute
goûtez le ministre de l'intérieur au
moment où nous vous parlons c'est bon
merci alors il sert et exprimer cet
après midi il était redevenu premier
ministre et il était interpellé par le
président du groupe
lr à l'assemblée on écoute les échanges
entre ces sens jacques hommes et leurs
films vous êtes aujourd'hui incapable de
proposer un gouvernement crédible à la
france tancé le vide autour de vous
jusque quand cette mascarade va-t-elle
continuer monsieur le premier ministre
dans votre question j'ai entendu quelque
chose qui m'apparaît relever d'une forme
de fébrilité et d'impatience mais je
vais vous dire une chose monsieur jacob
nous ne transigerons en rien sur les
engagements qui ont été pris par le
président de la république nous mettrons
en oeuvre la politique que nous avons un
fichier et sur laquelle nous nous sommes
engagés aux élections présidentielle et
aux élections législatives jambes
sainte-marie edouard philippe il est
renforcée après cet échange où il est
inexistant comme les autres internautes
moi je trouve je trouvais l'internaute
extrêmement sévère edouard philippe et
déjà l'or s'est désolé car ils font
d'âge mais plus populaire que le
président de la république il est à 100
et 37 % derrière dans le dernier sondage
hawks à tous les deux oui mais à 32 et
39 enfin bon on verra mais en tout cas
il a été ces derniers mois il ya quand
même plutôt été davantage populaire ce
qui est d'ailleurs une tradition
maintenant sous le quinquennat les
premiers ministres seront davantage
populaires parfois considérablement que
le présent de la république ce ne sont
plus des boucliers au contraire ils ont
tendance à profiter attirer la lumière
vers je trouve qu'il voir philippe c'est
plutôt comment dirais-je a été plutôt
renforcé par les péripéties on va dire
de l'été qui ont affecté l'image du
président de la république l'image
personnelle mais qui ont fait que
finalement que lui il incarne il n'y a
qu'un de l'état il faut le dire de
manière assez assez convaincante et sa
discrétion n'est pas forcément un
handicap ce genre là dessus je veux pas
beaucoup de commentaires que j'entends
le but n'est pas forcément si vous
voulez d'être omniprésent et là il est
il se montre à la fois loyal discret et
il a tenu la maison si vous voulez quand
on voyait le présent la république
mobilisés par des affaires à ses
subalternes
je pense effectivement que qu'edouard
philippe avec le calme qui donne dont il
donne l'impression systématiquement tout
le temps sa façon de prendre la parole
sans mauvais jeu de mots sa hauteur de
vue le fait qu'ils dominent toujours
toutes les assemblées beaucoup c'est que
il
je pense qu'au contraire ils gagnent en
épaisseur et en consistance dans ces
moments de un peu instable un peu floués
et c'est presque un problème pour macron
qui apparaît comme étant plus plus
incertain plus plus dans le doute
sipa dans le doute en tout cas maladroit
c'est la question qui a quelque chose à
aux internautes
est-ce que selon vous emmanuel macron
reprend lama et ils font face avec ce
que vous dites parce qu'on n'a pas de
remaniement peut pas dire que pour le
moment ils reprennent la main
donc on sait pas qui va m comment il va
s'y prendre et quelle ampleur ça va
avoir c'est bien qu'on va en avoir
quelques uns qui vont sortir ça
m'étonnerait que madame nissan reste par
exemple en termes d'opinion qu'elle
remaniement a fait reprendre la main
aucun doute la question les régler c'est
pas un remaniement qui permet de
reprendre la main à un remaniement quand
il ya un changement premier ministre
changement va changer mais il faut ce
qu'il faut quand même pas misé
l'intérieur a donc il va pas mettre un
nouveau projet mixte et donc la question
est est ce que ce remaniement va
renforcer et doit philippe je pense que
oui je pense qu'il va ressources et
gagnons ce soit au maniement est ce
qu'il va être nommé il va avoir un
nouveau gouvernement donc nécessairement
ça ira bien pour lui
la deuxième question est ce que ça va
remettre la politique d manioc m'a
consolé rails et rebooster ses sondages
là je suis beaucoup plus prudent et j'ai
du mal à croire ça changera grand chose
dans les médias autant je considère que
seulement l'internaute est très sévère
ya aucune raison de dire qu'il est nul
qui sert à rien tu auras il fait plutôt
bien le job il est sérieux et c'est pour
autant moi je m'inscris pas dans cette
façon de voir kim on avait très
parisienne et résidant à l'éthique
alala edouard philippe était en train de
gnl mâcon de prendre la place nous non
il fait le job
il fait son boulot mais comment dire il
n'y a pas de il est nerveux - pourquoi
macron aujourd'hui baisse cédant son
action qui fait qu'ils baissent c'est
qu'il énerve les gens par plein de
fautes de comportement edouard philippe
ne fait comme est passé faute de ce
point de vue il est nerveux - même temps
y'a pas de lien de droit philippe à
l'opinion y'a pas d'incarnation de voir
philippe dans l'opinion
il n'y a pas de magnétisme d'avoir fait
une opinion il est là il fait bien le
job mais je crois pas qu'ils aient
aujourd'hui n'a pas construit quelque
chose de fort les questions sur edouard
philippe d'ailleurs on a on allonge et
c'est très difficile
la position du premier organisant la
vème république patron non non non mais
alors juste bien blanc doit être parent
dont je vous coupe il ya une chose dont
on attend qu'on attendait qu'on
annonçait depuis ces dernières heures
c'est qu'il devait présenter sa
démission au président et comment vous
interprétez le choix n'est pas absurde
d'abord qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
d'abord on a commencé la valve a
présenté le soir
et vas y vas être nommé le lendemain on
ne peut pas il veut pas dire de vacances
de l'état imaginez qui la moindre
événement il faut quand même que des
ministres pour donner des ordres aux la
police il faut faire en termes même
juridique on peut pas organiser la
vacance de l'état donc déjà de dire
qu'il démissionne le soir pour revenir
lendemain tu as état pur et deuxièmement
l'idée de démissionner pour être renommé
ça veut dire qu'il y aura un vote de
confiance un nouveau vote de confiance à
l'assemblée
est-ce que c'est l'intérêt aujourd'hui
de 2,2
de voir philippe retenter le redemander
un vote de confiance à l'assemblée
je pense que par rapport au présent il
ne peut que perdre mathématiquement il a
fait le plein la dernière fois il peut
pas avoir plus
en revanche il aura toujours quelques
centristes qui sont énervés qui vaudront
plus voter pour lui quelques joints de
vraiment goode qui était entre le ps et
les marcheurs qui diront oh non on n'est
pas content donc moi je vois pas bien
l'intérêt d'aller se refaire taper
dessus à l'assemblée pour à l'arrivée
avoir moins de avoir moins de deux ans
je crois que également y voir philippe à
un autre problème
je te leur jeu répondu sur le jugement
sur l'homme et la manière dont on vit là
il assume ses fonctions de premier
ministre à me paraît tout à fait correct
la houle a un problème plus politique
c'est que justement c'était une prise de
guerre manière remarquable la formation
du gouvernement d'edouard philippe a été
décisif pour décider pour les élections
législatives qui ont suivi et il a
permis aussi avec bruno le maire et
d'autres de drainer vers dans le foot
tient à l'exécutif de drainer de très
nombreux sympathisants de droite au
point d'ailleurs que emmanuel macron ça
paraît loin désormais en janvier et est
devenue majoritairement populaire 50 52
% c'était assez rare vous voyez
quelqu'un qui baise qui remonte comme ça
à présent la république nicolas sarkozy
l'avait fait mais c'est assez rare et
c'était grâce justement aux soutiens de
beaucoup de sympathisants de droite
notamment dans un contexte de mouvement
sociaux et là ce qui s'est passé durant
depuis janvier et qui s'est terriblement
accéléré ces derniers mois
c'est a été le retour le retour des
sympathisants de droite vers notamment
le parti la république oui donc si vous
voulez vous avez hélas edouard philippe
il sert à ça aussi notamment la
perspective des prochaines échéances
électorales
et ça pour l'instant ça ne marche plus
mais il est il est enfin quand même de
profiter du fait que ça va pas très bien
entre la france assume et le parti
communiste on se marie le pen et dupont
aignan donc l'opposition n'est pas
vraiment là pour qu'on ferait donc il a
quand même s'ils n'ont pas pour sarkozy
ou au lond l'opposition reste quand même
très divisés ils sont que c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
ce que dit jérôme sainte marie c'est
qu'apparemment à droite
il ya un nouveau soutien qui revient
dans l'opinion et que pour l'instant
wauquiez ok cascio n'agissent pas ça non
en tout cas c'était très net c4 n est là
que dans les soutiens au gouvernement
soutient au pouvoir et au président de
la république les beaucoup de
sympathisants de droite qui étaient
venus sont aujourd'hui reparti et donc
vous l'avez vous tombez à 25-30 % de
bonnes opinions pour le présent de la
république
à droite c'est un peu plus qu'à gauche
sa coupe que ce qui reste de la gauche
enfin et ça c'est très important
notamment parce que il y avait plein de
catégories sociales qui votent davantage
pour la droite que les autres qui ont
été très déçus je pense évidemment aux
retraités et juste pour finir
et effectivement on dit qu'après n'a pas
de problème et si on est en crise
politique majeure enfin majeur crise
politique ça n'aboutira pas à une
révolution mais et c'est bien tout
simplement parce qu'il ya absence de
résultats et de véritables attentes
fondamentales français le chômage sont
en train de baisser
toutes ces questions là ne serait plus
je me suis même pas sûr que dire des
choses comme jospin il a des bons
résultats économiques le chômage baisse
la croissance revient tout va bien il
est même pas au second tour d'élection
présidentielle kofi certes très
populaire c'est beaucoup plus qu il est
même pas au second tour ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué le soutien des
électeurs de droite comme il pouvait la
voir mais ses électeurs de droite pour
l'instant ne sont pas ne se sont pas
arrangées n'ont plus d'eau qui sont
encore dans une position attentiste
d'une certaine façon qui peut aussi
bouger et quand on voit simplement vos
questions prend le baromètre des
personnalités comme on l'a vu
alors ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire
et c'est plein de contradictions va il
est quand même parmi les derniers
le show qu'on souhaite voir exercer des
responsabilités
c'est quand même
un peu un peu gênant loin derrière on va
continuer à suivre ça dans les
prochaines heures si il y à une annonce
d'une façon ou d'une autre et bien bien
sûr on l'a on la retransmettra si elle
est faite sur le perron de l'elysée
notamment où on vous la donnera dans le
courant de cette émission je laisse le
dernier mot aux internautes un vrai ça
tu repars dans qui nous dit l'arrêt un
propos de vous philippe turn a raison de
dire que macro et bienvenue à l'étranger
non seulement c'est vrai mais surtout le
seul depuis très longtemps
macabre ditto nous dit edouard philippe
n'a pas caché son intention possible de
retourner à la politique locale ça n'est
jamais bon signe
et il ajoute edouard philippe est à mon
avis dans la lignée des premiers